the question whether mathematics is
um invented or discovered whether there
is this world of pure forums and so on
is another paradoxical question which
doesn't have a simple answer
like whether electron is a particle or a
wave
from one point of view yes it's true
and
just the fact that so many
mathematicians today actually subscribe
to this idea
gives it a certain credibility because
that's what we feel we do feel that we
dive into dive into that mindscape so to
speak you know but the very structured
Minds key where you know I wrote In Love
In Math that
you know the Enchanted Gardens of
platonic reality you know so where all
this fruit is grows you know and then we
we might think it gives you this sort of
romantic sense of an explorer and um
someone may be stuck in a you know some
provincial town in Russia for instance
but have the sense of Magellan you know
of traveling around the world it's just
not in the world that we usually think
of
so it's it's one point of view but the
other point of view is that yes it is a
human process of course it is I mean it
is you cannot deny that it's human
beings who have so far discovered new
mathematics and I do not deny the
possibility that a computer programs
will be able to discover new mathematics
but so far it's been humans so it
whatever it is uh whether it's
discovered or invented it is a human
activity what that the possibility that
paradoxes are actually fundamental right
to reality right and really really
internalizing that that we exist in a
world of not forms but of paradoxes
Bingo and so it's like what I said
but if you think it's weird and I agree
with you as a recovering uh addict to
knowledge yeah you know but I am liking
it more and more because there's so much
freedom in it
uh and like like Niels Bohr said you
know I quoted that earlier
the the opposite of a great truth is
another great truth he's pointing out to
this fact that
you know and he also said that some some
things in quantum physics are so
complicated the only way you can speak
of them is in poetry
so in other words what is it about
poetry what is about art
why are we so drawn to that why are we
so captivated captivated by by those
forms of by they are not intellectual
necessarily they are not when you look
at a painting that you like when you
listen to music
that you love you get lost in it you get
absorbed in it it makes it make you cry
it can make you laugh it can make you
remember something it can make you feel
more confident or can make you feel sad
or happy and so on what is this all
about is it really is just some play
between some kind of like silophone play
or some neurons or hitting on each other
is it really that only maybe
it could be it could be both I'm just
worried about kids these days that might
live in a world of paradoxes you know if
there's no God everything is possible I
mean I just they'll have a little too
much fun and we have to put a constraint
have you looked at the world lately I
haven't checked in in a while you think
it's perfect the way it is now the world
without paradoxes
we believe that every end every question
can be answered as yes or no that it is
this or that and if you disagree with me
you're my enemy
wouldn't that be interesting if this
21st century is a transition into seeing
the world as a world of paradoxes I'm
telling you you know people predicted
that you know the age of Aquarius you
know that the access of the of the Earth
is rotating uh relative to the plane in
which the earth goes around the sun and
the period of this revolution is around
2000 years
so there is a traditional uh way of
measuring that by this
eras you know the the ages so the
previous one is called the age of Pisces
because of the constellation of Isis
that it points to so to speak you know
and now it's it's you know as in famous
musical hair they said the age of
Aquarius is upon us
so the different people dated
differently but
um some somewhere around the time where
we are finding ourselves how interesting
right is all the strife and all them
difficulties the world is experiencing
this might actually be the transition to
something more harmonious wouldn't it be
nice